Amen.
You can be seated. We are gonna witness
the celebration of a baptism
Well church. We get
to continue on
and just praising God for what he's done.
Uh, this is Dennis here and he is the honor
and privilege to just continue to witness to all of you
and anyone that might see this, of
what God has done in his life.
And it's incredible. Dennis, a cult student at ou, uh,
and the Lord's been working in his life.
He came to faith in high school
and it has just been incredible to hear of
what God has been doing in his life and just growing him
and, uh, putting him in leadership positions
and faith organizations.
So it's awesome to watch it happen.
So today we get to celebrate and witness what God has done.
There's rejoicing happening in heaven
because one who repented.
So we want to praise God for what he's done.
Dennis, get to baptize me, my brother, in the name
of the Father, the Son and the Holy Spirit
Church.
Let me, let me pray for us.
And would you pray for Dennis as well?
God, we thank you for your work in Dennis's life
and how you've transformed him, how you've used his church,
his parents, and everyone who's walked alongside him
to appoint him closer to you.
God, we celebrate, uh, what you've done in Dennis' life.
And God we pray that he would continue to walk, um, rest
of his days with you, uh,
and with people that come alongside him,
and he would point others to you.
God, such a witness that he will be to rest
of the world on light, on a campus at ou.
God, we're thankful for how you're at work
and what you're doing in Dennis' life.
In name we pray. Amen.